[Applause]
no man in the leagues made ten threes in
the game this year till now they busted
[Applause]
where is my unlimited range this little
curry does here if everybody's back to
that bother him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's trying to beat the whole team and
he might have just accomplished that on
that one move tine roll off the front
rim
[Applause]
you want to see a dribble move watch
this one double behind your back knock
it down and the bench is loving it come
to that Chris Paul takes it out under
the basket and suddenly goes two times
behind his back do we fall on the ground
and then finishes it off
[Applause]
he works on these shots look how far he
is I mean that said three on three
leagues four pointer ahead to curry
curry sets fires puts it up from way
downtown and the first half comes to it
in in dramatic fashion
they'll try to work behind screens
picked up here by Hardy shoots over
dude
the
[Applause]
they do have a timeout decide not to use
a curry way downtown our chef from curry
with six tension of second remaining
curry
what's the deepest behind the back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if that's not a top-10 place and you
could make the case with number one
there are less guys that can do that
then said that cuz windmill dunk
tomahawk dunk that's a special play by a
special talent